Na, was der Stefan erzählt hat, ist ja nicht der ganz aktuelle Stand. Es gibt inzwischen wirklich einen aktiven Handel, der irgendwie mit diesem High-Frequency-Trading von Aktien vergleichbar ist. Wie heißt das in Deutschland? Hochgeschwindigkeitshandel?
Ich glaube, man sagt das einfach ganz basi.
Und dabei ist es so, dass wenn du die Webseite aufrufst, dann wird einfach noch während deiner Seite ladet kommuniziert innerhalb des Netzwerks. Du, da gibt es gerade irgendjemanden, der klickt die Seite, der will da Werbung angeblendet bekommen. Gibt es da irgendwelche Interessanten? Und dann kann man sich innerhalb von Sekundenbruchteilen als Werbetreibende dafür anbieten. Ja, nehme ich, wenn das irgendwie nur so und so viel kostet. Und dann wird da der Anbieter wirklich live ausgewählt, sodass dort mit ähnlichen Problemen die Werbeanbieter inzwischen zu kämpfen haben, wie die HFT-Trader, die ihre Server dann immer noch eine Mikrosekunde näher an den Handelsplatz ranstellen, um dann da eher dabei zu sein.
Also das heißt, ich werde versteigert quasi als Nutzer?
Ich finde es ja auch sehr spannend, bei diesem HFT ist es ja ganz wichtig, schnell zu sein. Das heißt, man nimmt auch eher Glasfaser, weil die Übertragungsgeschwindigkeit höher ist als in Kupfer. Und näher dran, kürzere Leitungen, selbst Lichtgeschwindigkeit. Wird das dann irgendwann ein Treiber für Fiber to the Home im Entkundenmarkt?
Aber faszinierend.
Wir kriegen alle dicke Anschlüsse, damit uns schneller Werbung präsentiert werden kann.
Das ist ein echt großes Problem, dass du ja am Ende die Bandbreite dafür bezahlen musst, dass die Werbung auf dein Endgerät gespielt wird.
Und gerade die Mobile Betreiber finden das auch echt scheiße.
Halt, halt, halt, halt. Ich möchte an dieser Stelle fragen, da hab ich jetzt die ganze Zeit noch gar nicht dran gedacht. Ich lade ja tatsächlich nicht nur die Webseite, ich lade ja auch noch die Werbung. Das ist ja obendrauf, das heißt die Webseite wäre kleiner, wenn keine Werbung drin wäre. Dazu sind noch ungefähr, also nicht ungefähr, aber sozusagen wir haben jetzt als Daumenzahl gehört, das können auch mal 20 sein, Leute, die in dieser Werbung drin hängen, die also ihre eigenen Cookies setzen. Wie viel größer wird denn so eine Webseite, die ich mir lade, dadurch, dass Werbung drin ist?
Oh, ich glaube, da haben wir jemanden am Telefon, der uns dazu Auskunft geben kann.
Herzlich Willkommen.
Hallo.
Von ganz weit draußen zugeschaltet, THS. Hallo, guten Tag.
Ich kann leider nicht im Studio sein, aber das geht, glaube ich, auch so.
Nächstes Mal wieder. Du hast dir mal genauer angeschaut, wie das technisch aussieht. Und jetzt war gerade meine Frage, ich kam gerade so drauf, wie viel größer ist denn eigentlich eine Webseite, dadurch, dass die Werbung noch mitbringt?
Naja, wie viel größer die wird, habe ich nicht nachgeschaut. Ich habe halt mal geguckt. Also ich habe mich mit dem Thema aus einem ganz anderen Grund beschäftigt, weil ich um die Sicherheit der Rechner bange, die ja eben durch so Online-Werbenetzwerke halt auch ein bisschen minimiert wird. Und da hat mich mal interessiert, wie viele Requests setzt so ein Browser eigentlich ab, wenn man so ein Newsportal unsurft und dann da so zwei Minuten drauf rumklickt. Und da habe ich mal verschiedene Newsportale angeschaut und mal mitgeschnitten, was die so für Anfragen an Web-Server stellen.
Moment, du meinst jetzt Nachrichtenseiten, ganz normale Nachrichtenseiten. Und du wolltest sagen, von wie viel Servern dann die Informationen zusammenkommen, bis die Webseite vollständig angezeigt ist?
Korrekt. Also bis die Webseite vollständig angezeigt ist, so detailliert nun nicht. Also ich hab halt mal so zwei Minuten lang auf ein paar Artikel geklickt und zwei Rubriken Ressourcen angeschaut. Und dann hab ich mal verglichen und einfach mal geguckt, wie viele Server werden überhaupt kontaktiert und wie viele Server gehören dem Verlag eigentlich selber. Und das war eigentlich ganz interessant. Also ich hab da mal zum Beispiel bei Bild.de geguckt, bei Spiegel online, bei der Süddeutschen und der Zeit online. Und um jetzt einfach mal ein paar Zahlen in den Raum zu werfen, wir haben bei Sponnen und Bild.de bei zwei Minuten rumsurfen werden insgesamt um die 2500 HTTP-Anfragen vom Webbrowser an irgendwelche Server geschickt. Also 2500 mal fragt der Webbrowser irgendwelche Web-Server nach Daten.
Wie viele verschiedene Web-Server? Also mal abgesehen davon, dass es ganz schön viel ist, davon dass es nicht eine Webseite auch. Wie viele Server sind es, die da kontaktiert werden?
Das sind rund 180 bis 190 Server, also unterschiedliche Server. Und insgesamt, da ähneln sich zum Beispiel Bild und Sponnen und die Süddeutsche. Die Server, die von denen selber betrieben werden, liegen so im zweistelligen Bereich bei 12 oder 13 Stück. Das heißt, von 190 Servern, die bei Bild e eine Rolle spielen, wenn man da so drauf rumserft, gehören Bild quasi 13 Stück selber. Das heißt, nur über diese 13 Server haben die selbst die Kontrolle.
Warte, ich möchte ganz kurz sagen, es hat nicht direkt was mit Tüner, aber warum braucht man als eine Webseite 13 verschiedene Server, um eine Webseite anzuzeigen? Kannst du das kurz für technisch Unversierten erklären?
Das ist wahrscheinlich gar kein technisches Problem, sondern eher ein organisatorisches. Ich habe jetzt diese verschiedenen Serverbild oder Sponnen oder wem auch immer nur so zugeordnet, dass ich gesehen habe, okay, das ist eine Hostname oder eine Domain, die gehören quasi dem Verlag. So habe ich herausgefunden oder eben einfach mal angenommen, dass das die Server sind, die dem Verlag selber gehören.
Also quasi irgendwas mit spiegel.de?
Genau, und dann haben die halt irgendwie einen Host, einen Server für statische Inhalte wie Bilder, dann haben sie einen für eine bestimmte Rubrik, also bei bild.de, da gibt es ja dann irgendwie noch so autobild und so weiter. So kommt das halt zu den 13 eigenen Servern und das ist jetzt nicht so, ja, also wundert mich hinfalls nicht, dass so eine größere Webseite halt irgendwie so die Sachen so organisiert hat.
Du musst nicht lachen, teilweise sind die Services auch auf mehrere Server aufgeteilt, um den Datenverkehr zu reduzieren, weil du ja, also Cookies sendet dein Browser immer dorthin, wenn sie von einem Server kamen. Wenn du jetzt also irgendwie auf Spiegel gewesen bist und von denen, wie wir gehört haben, ganz viele Cookies eingesammelt hast, und du aber manchmal irgendwelche Ressourcen möchtest, die gar keine Cookies brauchen, dann tun sie die auf den extra Server, damit dein Browser dorthin nicht die Cookies senden muss. Die haben sich dieses Problem gemacht und dann lösen sie das Problem, indem sie einfach mehr Server machen.
Ja, aber die Datenmengen, die dann da vom Client Richtung Server übertragen werden, sind ja vergleichsweise gering. Also wenn man sich dann mal anschaut im Verhältnis zu irgendwelchen Werbevideos, die dann mal runtergeladen werden.
Die Bandbreite ist auch deutlich geringer nach oben.
Aber da gibt es noch sozusagen die anderen 177 Server, die jetzt noch übrig sind. Was machen die?
Ja, das ist eine gute Frage. Da kann man sich ja mal hinsetzen und das mal ganz genau anschauen. Also da fallen wirklich hunderte von Megabyte an, wenn man da mal so ein bisschen drauf rumklickt auf diesen ganzen Newsportalen. Und diese ganzen Daten, die da von diesen 190, 180 Servern geladen werden, das müsste man sich halt mal alles genau anschauen. Aber im Grunde genommen weiß man es eh nicht und normalen User interessiert das halt auch nicht, weil die Webseite wird angezeigt, fertig.
Markus hat ja vorhin schon erzählt, was er da sieht. Es sind genau dann unten diese Clickbait-Bilder, wo die sich auch keine Gedanken darum machen, wie groß diese Bilder jetzt sind, weil, herrje, die interessiert nicht, dass der Mobiluser da nur schmale Bandbreite hat und dann wird unten genau diese Box da eingeblendet, wo sie hoffen, dass da jemand draufklickt und dann natürlich die Werbebanner und natürlich das ganze Tracking. Da hängt ja auch ziemlich viel JavaScript dran, also dieser Code, der im Browser ausgeführt wird. Das muss ja am Ende irgendwie aus dem Internet auch auf die Rechner der Benutzer drauf.
Ja, da gibt es ganz viele Requests, die mit der Werbung zu tun haben. Da werden dann irgendwelche Tracking-URLs aufgerufen und irgendwelche JavaScripts gezogen, die dann wieder irgendwelche JavaScripte von anderen Servern ziehen, nur um am Ende irgendeinen Werbebanner anzuzeigen. Das ist ja, Entschuldigung, wir haben ja hier so etwas wie ein Adwar. Also die Werbetreibenden oder die Werbenetzwerke versuchen ja auch immer die Werbeblocker quasi auch auszutricksen und so weiter. Und ich denke, dass da halt auch viele unnötige Requests gemacht werden, nur um diesen Krieg irgendwann zu gewinnen.
Wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, kommst du an der Stelle ins Spiel, die wir vorhin schon mal kurz erläutert hatten, nämlich Stefan hat uns erzählt, dass die Werbung, die ausgeliefert wird, kommt ja nicht unbedingt von den Werbetreibenden oder der Agentur, die für die Online-Werbe zuständig ist, sondern als jemand, der Online-Werbung schaltet, kann ich auch sagen, ich möchte gerne, dass ihr die Online-Werbung von mir abholt. Also sagen, was da konkret im Browser angezeigt wird, dass es auf meinem Server liegt.
Und da kommst du doch jetzt ins Spiel, oder? Naja, wenn ich ein bisschen Geld habe, Stefan hatte das ja gesagt, wenn man mehr Geld in die Hand nimmt, dann kann man halt schon sehr genau spezifizieren, wie die Zielgruppe für meine Werbung aussehen soll. Nicht wahr? Also das geht dann schon. Ansonsten weiß ich nicht.
Aber auch eine Inhalte platzieren, das ist ja das Spannende. Also wirklich nicht nur sagen, ich hab hier ein Bildchen, zeig mal an. Sondern halt durchaus mehr.
Chart Software zum Beispiel. Und das ist eben der Grund, warum ich mich überhaupt mit dieser ganzen Thematik mal befasst habe. Weil mir das einfach zu wenig diskutiert wurde. Als diese AdWars losging, wo Bild.de angefangen hat, den Programmierer eines Umgehungswerkzeuges oder Algorithmuses. Das fing halt irgendwie an, dass Bild.de ja Adblocker ausgesperrt hat. Und es dann Leute gab, die gesagt haben, diese Sperre kann ich auch umgehen. Dann fing das halt an, dass es da eine juristische Auseinandersetzung gab. Und da hab ich mir gedacht, Leute, ihr sprecht hier die ganze Zeit über Adblocker. Dass ihr die Adblocker nutzt, um sich nur diesen ganzen bunten Werbekram nicht anzuzeigen. Mir geht es halt auch noch um die Sicherheit meines Rechners. Ich wollte halt da mal so ein bisschen das Bewusstsein dafür schaffen, dass das halt ein durchaus größeres Problem ist als unästhetische Werbung. Denn der Browser, der ja all diese ganzen Daten verarbeitet und ohne dass man die auch bewusst abruft von irgendwelchen Servern, der ist erstmal mit Chartsoftware konfrontiert. Und ja, da wollte ich einfach mal zeigen, was das für Konsequenzen und Folgen hat.
Du hast ja zu sagen, du definierst aber jetzt als Chartsoftware alles, was quasi nicht Webseite ist, die ich mir angucken will. Also quasi, ich gehe auf eine Nachrichtenwebseite und dann sagst du, Chartsoftware ist erstmal alles, was nicht zu der Webseite gehört.
Ja, nicht alles. Also Chartsoftware hat halt schon einen sehr speziellen Zweck, irgendwie den Benutzer in die Irre zu führen, den zu irgendeiner dummen Aktion zu verleiten oder eben, weiß ich, Schwachstellen auf dem Computer auszunutzen zum Beispiel. Also das sind eben Dinge, davon kriegt der Nutzer selber gar nichts mit oder der weiß auch nicht, dass er sich überhaupt in diese Gefahr begibt.
Ja, aber ich wollte gerade sagen, also ich hatte ja ganz am Anfang der Sendung erzählt, Werbung, die quasi mehr oder weniger irreführend ist und die mich dazu verleiten soll, was anzuklicken. Aber jetzt hast du gesagt, Lücken ausnutzen, das klingt ja wie ein Virus. Geht das tatsächlich über Online-Werbung?
Jaja klar, das geht. Das dachte er einfach. Natürlich geht das. Nein, also wenn wir uns jetzt einfach mal so, also wenn wir jetzt mal schauen, wie können wir Schadsoftware verbreiten. Unter Schadsoftware verstehe ich dann zum Beispiel so Sachen wie diese Krypto-Trojaner, Ransomware wie Loki und all diese ganzen Geschichten. Aber zum Beispiel auch irgendwelche Staats-Trojaner oder irgendwie Schadsoftware, die am Ende darauf aus sind, Geld von den Benutzer zu bekommen. Online-Banking-Trojaner und all diese ganzen Geschichten, die fängt man sich ja irgendwie ein. Oft werden die per E-Mail verschickt. Heutzutage öffnet aber keiner mehr so einen E-Mail-Anhang so leichtfertig und klickt dann auf irgendwelche Dateien, die von irgendwelchen fremden Leuten geschickt werden. Aber der Browser, der kriegt die angeboten, der lädt die runter und dann fühlt er halt ein bisschen Nervous-Script-Code aus und mit ein bisschen Pech hat der Browser halt gerade einen Bug und sorgt halt dafür, dass diese Schadsoftware dann auch auf dem Rechner installiert wird.
Moment, Moment, Moment, halt. Jetzt kann man ja den online Werbetreibenden viel nachsagen. Sie sammeln unsere Daten, sie belästigen uns und so weiter und so fort. Aber entschuldige, die werden noch nicht sozusagen Schadsoftware in die Werbung einbinden.
Ja, doch, das tun sie einfach, weil sie ja die Kontrolle verloren haben.
Halt. Also ich kann doch da hingehen und sagen, hier, ich möchte für WLAN-Kabel werben und hier ist mein tolles Banner und das zeigt er jetzt bitte an und dann gebe ich denen das und die machen das. Punkt.
Die gucken nicht nach?
Was sollen die denn nachgucken? Ob das WLAN-Kabel kippt oder was?
Nein, nein, nein, warte, warte, warte. Also nur um das sozusagen Schritt für Schritt zu machen. Also du gehst halt hin und sagst, ich möchte eine Werbung schalten. Und zwar diese Werbung ist hier. So soll die Werbung aussehen. Also die Werbung ist anscheinend nicht nur ein Bild, also was man wirklich übergibt, sondern es ist ein Programmcode. Und denen gucken die nicht nach, was der macht?
Ja, nein, das tun sie nicht.
Das ist ein automatisiertes Prozess, du überweist das Geld und...
Selbst wenn sie es täten, wir kommen ja dann, also wenn sie den Content überprüfen würden, der von den Werben denn da submitted wird, dann haben wir ja so ein Sicherheitsmodell, und ich würde das gerne in Anführungszeichen setzen, wie diese Appstores von Microsoft, Apple, Android und so weiter. Da werden halt Anwendungen hingeschickt, die prüfen dann diese Anwendungen nach diversen Kriterien und sagen halt so, ja, ist eine tolle Anwendung, ist jedenfalls keine Schadsoftware, ist jetzt also sicher, weil ist jetzt im Appstore. Und da wurde ja in der Vergangenheit auch schon oft genug gezeigt, dass selbst solche Securitychecks oder eben solche Überprüfungen der Apps, dass man die halt auch leicht umgehen kann. Und das ist hier um ein Vielfaches einfacher, weil die Werbenetzwerke ja auch vorsehen, dass du den Content selber bereitstellst auf deinen eigenen Servern. Werbetreibende, die halt sagen, ja, ich möchte auch niemanden belästigen. Ich möchte halt auch nicht, dass ich die Webseite langsamer aufbaue, nur weil ich hier mein eigenes Werbebanner habe. Die werden halt sagen so, ne, ne, packt das mal bei euch in die Cloud, dann kommt das bei den Nutzern halt auch schnell an und die Webseite lädt sich schnell. Aber man hat die Möglichkeit, das auf einem eigenen Webserver zu tun. Und wer hindert mich dann daran, meinen eigenen JavaScript-Code und mein eigenes Programm, was ich da in das Werbe-Netzwerk gedrückt habe, zehn Minuten später auszutauschen?
Ja, entschuldige mal, das ist doch ein riesig, riesig großes Scheuntor, wo jetzt sozusagen als kriminelle Natur, würde ich denken, also wenn ich jetzt zum ersten Mal höre so, was für eine geile Idee, ich werde sofort meine ganze Schadsoftware nur noch über Online-Werbung verbreiten. Jetzt schreien aber nicht alle, dass ihre Rechner infiziert werden wollen. Also wie realistisch ist denn das Bedrohungs-Szenario?
Das ist sehr realistisch. Ich hab das selber gemacht. Im Rahmen eines Vortrags habe ich das mal demonstriert, dass ich eine Schadsoftware hochladen kann. Und da habe ich zwei verschiedene Exploits für Firefox Webbrowser über dieses Ad-Netzwerk verbreitet.
Kurz Exploits, kleine Programme, die Sicherheitslücken ausnutzen.
Genau, und die sorgen dann dafür, dass so eine Schadsoftware installiert werden kann. Statt einer Schadsoftware habe ich dann nur den Taschenrechner gestartet. Aber das sollte zumindest mal demonstrieren, dass das durchaus möglich ist. Und das passierte ja auch in der letzten Zeit sehr oft, dass einige Webseiten Schadsoftware verteilt haben. Also da gibt es einige in Deutschland, Europa, auf der ganzen Welt, gibt es viele Verlage, die da völlig hilflos zusehen mussten, wie ihr Werbepartner, ihr Werbenetzwerk, die Leser des Newsmagazins mit Schadsoftware zugeschrissen haben.
Erst letzte Woche gerade hat irgendwie eine große deutsche Online-Zeitung sämtliche Werbung schnell abgeschaltet, weil einer ihrer Werbepartner dort...
Und das interessante dabei ist, dass es jetzt auch ganz gezielt auf den Mobile-Bereich ging. Also das war ja eine sehr stark auf den mobilen Leserkreis zugeschnittene Werbung. Das heißt, das war halt so diese andere Variante. Da wurden nicht Exploits und so weiter verschickt. Das waren dann so Overlay-Geschichten, um die Leute zu täuschen. Also das geht dann so ein bisschen in Richtung Social Engineering.
Ihr PC ist infiziert, klicken Sie jetzt hier, um diese Desinfektionssoftware runterzuladen.
Und das kennt man ja aus E-Mails. Ihr kriegt auch immer wieder mal E-Mails, wo drinnen steht so hier, hier ist eine Rechnung. Wenn du die bis morgen nicht bezahlt hast, steht das ein Kassounternehmen bei dir vor der Tür. Und in dem Moment, wo der Benutzer so eine Information liest und das irgendwie plausibel für ihn ist, wird er darauf reagieren und dann da halt draufklicken. Also wenn da eine Rechnung von der Telekom kommt oder irgendeinem anderen Dienstleister, wo der Benutzer irgendwie in der letzten Zeit was eingekauft hat, dann kann das durchaus sein, dass er dann auf irgendein PDF klickt, was schadhafte Inhalte hat. Und genauso funktioniert das dann in diesen Werbenetzwerken mit so einem JavaScript-Overlay-Geschichten. Da wird dem Nutzer einfach gesagt, so, uah, du hast hier ein Virus, klick hier, um den Virus zu entfernen. Und in Wirklichkeit lädt er dadurch erst in Wirklichkeit die Schadsoftware herunter und installiert die. Aber es erscheint ihm in diesem Moment plausibel. Und deswegen ist es auch noch sehr verbreitet, auf dieser Social-Engineering-Ebene solche Angriffe zu fahren. Das betraf jetzt hier in diesem Fall, was Erdgeser angesprochen hat, tatsächlich nur mobile Clients. Die haben halt so für Mobile Clients spezielle Werbepartner. Und da haben sie dann eben, je nachdem, ob dann Android oder ein iPhone ankam, gesagt, so ja hier, update mal auf die aktuelle Version.
Aber das heißt ja, wenn ich dieses Targeting mir zu Ende denke, man kann ja wahrscheinlich nicht nur sagen, ich möchte sozusagen junge 22-jährige Männer aus Trepplo Köpenick, sondern ich möchte auf Leute targeten, die den Firefox benutzen. Müsste doch gehen, oder?
Ja, das geht ganz einfach. Aber das kann auch am Ende des Javascript entscheiden, ob es jetzt irgendwie einen Exploit ausprobiert.
Ich will ja meine Werbung mit dem Startcode nur dort schalten, wo der Startcode auch wirklich anschlägt, oder?
Vielleicht will man sich vorher noch die Kunden aussuchen, die wirklich Geld haben. Also vielleicht eher Manager-Magazin als irgendwo auf build.de oder so.
Das ist ja nach Postleitzahl.
Wenn du die Rechner von irgendwelchen Vorständen zerhacken willst, dann inserierst du halt wahrscheinlich nicht im Angelmagazin, sondern tatsächlich im Managermagazin.
Holy shit, möchte ich an dieser Stelle mal sagen.
Ansonsten, was Bert gerade noch nicht angesagt hat, ist, dass du als Werbetreibender auch selber Ziel eines Angriffs sein kannst. Du musst ja nicht mal selber deinen Kunden was Böses wollen, sondern wenn du erst mal in so einem Werbenetzwerk drin bist und dort die Reichweite hast, kannst du natürlich auch selber angegriffen werden, damit dein Content ausgetauscht wird.
Warte mal, ich hab ne Idee. Die Leute, also diese Adserve Companies, die die Werbung verteilen, die benutzen ja dazu wahrscheinlich ne Software. Und diese Software kann Sicherheitslücken haben? Und ist online? Das heißt, man kann die also auch angreifen und dann...
Und der andere Punkt, der vorhin noch zu kurz gekommen ist, Entschuldige, wenn ich nicht unterbreche, ist, dass es nicht unbedingt irgendwie groß JavaScript irgendwas braucht. Es war irgendwie vor einem Monat oder zwei ging rum, dass für das ziemlich häufig verwendete Bildformat PNG auf den Geräten mit dem Apfel drauf so ein Problem gab, wenn dort, naja, Leute daran rumgefummelt haben. Also PNG ist ein Bildformat. Genau. Und wenn du dann Bilder in diesem Format auf deinem Apple Endgerät dir angeguckt hast, dann ist da der Browser geplatzt und hat irgendwas ausgeführt, was du nicht wolltest. Das heißt, du musst da nicht mal Javascript, Mammel, Magie deployen, sondern es reicht, wenn du in das Werbenetzwerk speziell vor präparierte PNGs reist. Und wenn die dann nicht noch mal explizit angeguckt werden, was aber glücklicherweise einige ISPs, also einige mobile Netzanbieter, dann schon gemacht haben, die dann bestimmte Dinge rausgefiltert haben, wo sie wussten, das ist die Telefone.
Was man eigentlich auch nicht will. Das ist ja sozusagen das Internetprovider, die eigentlich die Datenseite verschlüsselt ist. Ich möchte an THS noch zwei Fragen stellen, die ich loswerden möchte, bevor wir ihn wieder entlassen. Die erste ist, das heißt also, Online-Werbung abschalten durch den Adblocker oder was auch immer ist nicht nur sinnvoll für den Datenschutz und weil ich damit Platz spare, sondern es minimiert, also es macht die Sicherheitsschwankung, wie ich mich jetzt aussetze, auch kleiner. Das habe ich richtig verstanden.
Genau, so sehe ich das auf jeden Fall.
Und dann komme ich auf Webseiten, wo dann gesagt wird, hey, du hast einen Adblocker und wir sind doch eigentlich cool. Also du bist cool. Wir sind auch eine coole Webseite. Und vielleicht wird es ja doch, damit wir Geld verdienen können. Aber in dem Fall sollte ich deiner Meinung nach sagen, so nähe ich das den Adblocker an, weil ihr könnt mir gar nicht garantieren, dass das, was ihr mir als Werbung anzeigt, wirklich sauber ist.
Korrekt. Die Verlage können das einfach nicht garantieren, weil die haben, die kriegen ja diesen Inhalt nicht ein einziges Mal zu sehen. Also die spielen ja nicht mal Proxy oder so. Die sagen halt nur, hier ist der Artikel, den du gerne lesen wolltest. Und im Übrigen, der da hinten hat noch eine Produktinformation für dich. Lad das mal bei dem.
Okay, aber im Versuch sozusagen ausgewogen zu sein, gibt es denn überhaupt eine technische, ich red jetzt nur von einer technischen Form von Online-Werkung, wo du sagen würdest, das wäre eine Form, da könnte ich mich mit anfreunden, dass mir angezeigt wird, ich red jetzt wirklich nur von der Technik, von der Sicherheit, von der Security.
Was ist mit so Sachen, wo du nur einen Link definieren kannst, der zur richtigen Zeit aufploppt?
Ich weiß nicht, man kann die Gefahren schon einschränken, also nicht beseitigen, aber einschränken, indem man zum Beispiel sagt, wir verzichten auf bestimmte Dateiformate. Also auf einer seriösen Webseite haben irgendwie Flash-Programme oder Java-Applets einfach nichts mehr zu suchen, sieht man aber leider auch noch viel zu häufig. Das ist ein Einfallstore für allen möglichen Unsinn. Das muss halt einfach mal weg. Wenn die Verlage auch noch ein bisschen Druck auf diese Ad-Netzwerke ausüben würden, könnten die sicherlich eine weitere technische Maßnahme umsetzen, um das Risiko zu minimieren. Das heißt, man muss denen aber auf einer ganz anderen Ebene begegnen, nämlich mit Verträgen und Vertragsstrafen, wenn am Ende doch irgendwas passieren sollte. Vorher wird sich da wahrscheinlich nichts tun.
Es bleibt dir am Namen der Plattform hängen. Du klickst dann wieder in deinelieblingszeitung.de und plötzlich hast du einen Trojaner installiert und bleibt das nicht bei dem Werbenetzwerk als Imageverlust hängen, sondern bei meinelieblingszeitung.de.
Darf ich dir noch was Schlimmes zum Abschluss sagen?
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das jetzt noch vertrage, aber mach.
Doch, doch, doch, ganz schnell. Als TRS was gerade erwähnt hat, ging mir noch gerade in den Sinn, dass wir das im letzten Chaosradio in den NerdNews hatten. Es gibt nämlich für all das, was TRS von Hand gemacht hat, ein fertiges Exploit-Kit, das dir automatisch die Sicherheitslücken raussucht. Und du hattest nach Erfolgsquoten von sowas gefragt. Bei diesem Exploit-Kit, das nämlich analysiert wurde, zehn Prozent der angegriffenen Systeme waren auch tatsächlich exploitbar. Das heißt, die haben einfach mal mit einem Angriff 148.000 Maschinen eingesammelt. Wenn du 148.000 Maschinen irgendwie verschlüsselst, um dann da irgendwie Geld zu erpressen von, sagen wir mal, 200 Euro umgerechnet pro Maschine, dann weißt du, was da als Gewinn abfällt.
Ja, es gibt da dieses geile Framework namens Metasploit. Die haben so ein Autopone-Modul. Das hatte ich auch hier in diesem Rahmen mal mit benutzt.
Hört sich mittlerweile an, es ist wahrscheinlicher, dass ich mir was einfange, wenn ich Werbung anmache, als wenn mir Werbung angezeigt wird. Na ja, gut, das ist vielleicht noch ein kleines bisschen übertrieben. TAS, vielen Dank. Vielen Dank A, für die Arbeit, die du gemacht hast, und B, dass du uns hier versucht hast zu erklären. Danke schön.
Gern, ja, viel Spaß noch.
Ebenso mit Adblocker hoffe ich. Bis dann, tschüss.
Also was wir eigentlich wollen, sind dann am Ende reine Plain Text Werbung, ja?
Naja, aber das ist ja die Frage, ob man das so sagt. Weil selbst wenn jetzt ein Anbieter sagen würde, ich garantiere dir, dass die Werbung so und so ist, ich kann das als User nicht unterscheiden. Also Plain Text Werbung, also sagen nur reiner Text, das wäre wahrscheinlich, da würden alle Werbe treiben und sagen, das ist doof. Das heißt, man würde sich wahrscheinlich, wenn, dann darauf einigen, dass man sagt, okay, nur sozusagen Bildformate, die als sicher gelten.
Also keine.
Starship, ja.
Alle Bildformate hatten in der Vergangenheit.
Ja, aber das ist nur für die theoretische Diskussion. Also nehmen wir mal an, es gäbe sowas. Aber ich kann ja als Nutzer nicht unterscheiden, ist da sozusagen nur ein trockenes Bild eigentlich oder bringt dieses Bild wieder Kohle? Das weiß ich ja alles nicht. So ein Siegel wäre schon cool.
Und wenn sich die Verlage darauf einigen, dass alles, was an Werbeinformationen dort ausgeliefert wird, geht einmal von ihren Servern unter ihrer Kontrolle, wäre ja schon mal 90% der Einfallstore geschlossen. Man könnte dann einfach gleich darauf reagieren, wenn man merkt, dass da die eigenen Nutzer angegriffen werden und das abschalten und muss nicht darauf warten, dass es dann vielleicht der Werbepartner für einen macht.
Aber solange der Markt halt da ist, um noch eine Millisekunde vor dem Ausliefern irgendwie den maximalen Preis noch rauszuholen, solange es so läuft, wird das halt nicht passieren.
Derzeitiger Stand nach 3, 5 Stunden von 4, 5 Stunden Chaosradio ist nur noch mit Adblocker. Mehr gleich, jetzt erst mal Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr.
Raus aus dem Alltag, rein in den Sommer.
Fritz und Festivals.
Wir präsentieren euch diesen Sommer das Kosmonautfestival mit geheimem Headliner Boi und Casper. Das Piece by Piece und das Helene Beach Festival mit Matzen Fritz Kalkbrenner und Jennifer Rostock. Das Lollapalooza und das Splash Festival mit Mac Miller, den Beginnern und Wiz Khalifa. Fritz und Festivals. Raus aus dem Alltag. Rein in den Sommer.
Fritz Nachrichten.
Mit Timo Maschewski.
Bundespräsident Gauck hat davor gewarnt, aus Angst vor Fremdem in Deutschland hysterisch zu werden. Beim Katholikentag in Leipzig sagte Gauck, wichtig sei auch zu prüfen, wie realistisch die vorgebrachten Sorgen seien. Die Erfahrungen hätten gezeigt, dass Ängste oft unbegründet sind. Als Beispiel nannte Gauck die Anti-Islam Demos in Sachsen. Dort gäbe es aber relativ wenig Menschen, die Sachsen über Fremden könnten, sagte Gauck. Dort, wo es schon viele Moscheen gäbe, gäbe es auch viel weniger Vorurteile. Wie kann die Weltwirtschaft weiter angekurbelt werden? Darüber haben die Staats- und Regierungschefs der sieben großen Industrieländer heute auf ihrem Gipfeltreffen in Japan gesprochen. Sie wollen eine Initiative verabschieden, die unter anderem dafür sorgen soll, dass die Menschen besser gebildet werden und auch mehr Frauen arbeiten können. Ein anderes wichtiges Thema war die Flüchtlingskrise. Kinsekanzlerin Merkel geht aber nicht davon aus, dass sich bei dem Gipfel Staaten konkret verpflichten, mehr Flüchtlinge aufzunehmen oder mehr Geld bereitzustellen. Mit spezieller Unterwassertechnik wollen französische Experten die Flugschreiber der verunglückten Egypt Air Maschine finden. Von Corsica aus hat sich ein Vermessungsboot auf den Weg gemacht. Es soll in den nächsten Tagen an der Absturzstelle ankommen. Das Schiff hat Detektoren an Bord, die die Signale orten können, die die Blackbox automatisch sendet. Falls auch das nichts bringt, könnte ein Unterwasser-Roboter zum Einsatz kommen. Das Egypt Air Flugzeug war vor einer Woche auf dem Weg von Paris nach Cairo ins Mittelmeer gestürzt. In Berlin nutzen bisher nur wenige arme Menschen die Möglichkeit, sich Zuschuss für die Miete zu holen. Stadtentwicklung-Senator Geisel sagte dem RBB, bisher hätten erst gut 700 Haushalte einen Antrag gestellt. 26.000 Mieter dürften das aber tun. Seit Jahresbeginn können sich Mieter den Zuschuss sichern, wenn sie in einer Sozialwohnung leben und mehr als 30 Prozent ihres Nettoeinkommens für die Miete ausgeben müssen. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen Berlin-Treptow hat 12 Grad und Charlottenburg 15 Grad, Potsdam und Carlo melden 12 Grad, Neuropin 13 Grad und Eberswalde 14 Grad. Bis auf 8 Grad kann es sich im Laufe der Nacht noch abkühlen, der Himmel klart immer weiter auf, Regen ist erst mal nicht in Sicht. Im Laufe des Tages ziehen neue Wolken rein, die später auch Regen mit sich bringen können. Die Temperaturen bewegen sich so zwischen 20 und 23 Grad. Stadtverkehr Berlin auf der A100, dem Stadtring in Richtung Wedding ist zwischen Buschkruge Allee und Gradesstraße die linke Spur gesperrt. Der Tiergarten-Tunnel ist außerdem wegen Wartungsarbeiten gesperrt, und zwar in beiden Richtungen. Vorsicht in Brandenburg auf der A10, dem westlichen Berliner Ring in Richtung Dreieckhafelland. Zwischen Föben und Leest sind Wildschweine auf der Autobahn. Vorsicht auch im Kreis Märkisch-Oderland auf der B168. Zwischen Darmstorf und dem Abzweig nach Liebenhof liegen Gegenstände. Dort, wo es geht, euch eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn ihr Fritz für die Hosentasche wollt, mit Livestream, Studio Message, Podcasts und jede Menge mehr, dann holt euch doch die Fritz-App. Kostenlos und werbefrei in eurem App oder Play Store.
Heute Chaosradio Mülmün und ich kann aus den letzten dreieinhalb Stunden schon mal sagen, wir werden alle sterben und zwar durch Online-Werbung. Also ich habe in den letzten dreieinhalb Stunden gelernt. Online-Werbung verursacht zusätzlichen Datenverkehr, es spioniert uns aus und es macht den Rechner unsicher, weil es ein Einfallstore Verscharsoftware ist. Das heißt, es spricht momentan eigentlich nichts dafür, Online-Werbung zuzulassen, weil das scheint mir...
Du hast zwar noch ein paar Dinge vergessen, aber...
Entschuldigung, du stirbst durch die Guillotine, den Galgen und Feuer. Da muss man jetzt nicht irgendwie noch die Reichstrecke, die man ziehen muss.
Das ist noch schmerzvoller als was du da gerade behauptest.
Wieso, was?
Wie dein Rechner wird noch langsamer, die Webseiten laden langsamer, bis du es ankieken kannst.
Hab ich schon gesagt.
Was?
Zusätzlicher Datending.
Nie, auch um wie der Browser führt er noch den ganzen Tag, was kommt aus?
Ja genau, das zusätzliche Datending ist zu sagen, das macht mehr Traffic. Also wenn du mobil unterwegs bist, schlürft es an deinem Guthaben. Der Akku irgendwie geht schneller runter, weil da dann Dinge ausgeführt werden, das Handy wird warm, das ist alles ganz, wie gesagt, alles ganz völlig. Tatsächlich haben uns auch die Leute, also Hörer haben gehört und Hörerinnen, und haben uns einen geschrieben. Und tatsächlich ist die erste Frage von Gino, der hat gefragt, was denn dagegen hilft getrackt zu werden. Also wir haben ja ganz am Anfang auch erklärt, dass sozusagen die Online-Werbung in den Browsern immer auch ganz genau guckt, ja wer ist denn da, wo haben wir den Schumar gesehen, was haben wir für Daten über den, und fragt, ob eine VPN dafür hilft. Mal kurz erklären, was ein VPN ist und warum das nicht hilft.
Ein VPN ist ein ziemlich großer Begriff, aber wie er denn gerade meint, ist, dass du eine verschlüsselte Verbindung zu irgendeinem Rechner im Internet herstellst und all deinen Datenverkehr nicht mehr sichtbar für dein Internetanbieter direkt bei ihm ins Internet schickst, sondern bei dem Server, mit dem du da die verschlüsselte Verbindung aufgenommen hast. Das heißt, du stopbst es einmal in einen Tunnel, auf der anderen Seite kommt aus dem Tunnel wieder raus und du erscheinst so, als ob du an irgendeiner Stelle im Internet dich befindest, wo du eigentlich gar nicht bist.
Wollen wir uns noch mal genau überlegen, was wir gerade gesagt haben. Dann kann das leider auch gar nichts bringen. Also VPNs werden immer mit Sicherheit und nicht Trackbarkeit oder so völlig zu Unrecht in Verbindung gebracht, weil am Ende steht ja immer noch der Browser. Und zwar genau der Browser, wo die Cookies drauf sind. Und der Browser, der diese einmalige Konfiguration hat, die sich wieder auslesen lässt. Und dabei ist es völlig egal, ob ich da in Triptoköpenik rauskomme oder in Timbuktu. Der Gegenseite ist das völlig egal. Der ist eigentlich total klar, das ist trotzdem immer noch derselbe Browser.
Es sei denn, man hat den Browser speziell konfiguriert, jetzt nicht als VPN, sondern Tor zum Beispiel bringt seinen eigenen Browser mit. Der versucht, all diese Fingerprinting-Möglichkeiten weitestmöglich zu umgehen. Unter anderem startet er zum Beispiel immer mit der gleichen Bildschirmgröße. Egal, wie groß sein Bildschirm ist, der Browserfenster hat immer die gleiche Größe. Wir haben uns da schon ein paar Gedanken gemacht. Das Versuch, das weitestgehend zu umgehen, ist natürlich auch nicht perfekt.
Es hat jetzt nicht direkt was mit zu tun, aber er fragt außerdem noch, ob es einen VPN auch so was wie kostenlos gibt. Da ist die Antwort eher nein. Beziehungsweise, wenn es einen kostenlosen VPN gibt, dann ist es wahrscheinlich...
Tor ist eigentlich ein kostenloses VPN.
Ja, also es gibt diesen wunderschönen Spruch, wenn du nicht dafür bezahlst, bist du nicht der Kunde, sondern das Produkt. Opera hat dich gerade zum Produkt gemacht. Also Opera ist ein Browserhersteller, die bieten gerade so was an, was sie VPN nennen, was aber im wesentlichen bloßen Webproxy ist. Und deren Deal ist halt, wir verschleien eure IP-Adresse, dafür leitet ihr allen euren Treffik über uns und wir können den sehen. Also ob man das jetzt machen will.
Hey, das heißt nicht mein Internetanbieter kann mich verfolgen, sondern ein Opera. Gut. Zweite Frage von Roberto, der fragt... Ach so, bei dem geht es um Handy-Ding. Und er sagt sozusagen, naja, okay, das heißt, wenn ich die Werbung auf dem Handy runterlade, dann zerrt das ja tatsächlich in meinem Traffic. Also wenn er mehr Daten runtergeladen. Und er fragt, wenn ich jetzt einen Werbeblocker installiere auf dem Handy, wird dann die Werbung trotzdem runtergeladen und dann nicht ausgeführt? Oder ist sozusagen schon, ist die Werbung dann komplett weg im Sinne von, die wird gar nicht erst geladen?
Kommt drauf an. Also manchmal... Also meistens wird sie gar nicht erst runtergeladen. Aber in einigen Fällen, wenn zum Beispiel der Server das Ausliefern des Inhalts davon abhängig macht, ob du die Werbung runtergeladen hast, dann ist dein Werbeblocker so eingestellt, dass es runterlädt und dann vor Ort auf deinem Telefon durch, was ersetzt, was du dann nicht angezeigt bekommst.
Also es kommt dann zu sagen, darauf andre ich die Webseite unterwegs. Die andere Frage ist, was er fragt, ob ein Werbeblocker, ist das eine zusätzliche App, die auch im Hintergrund arbeitet und dann selber wiederum auch Akku verbraucht?
Ja, aber deutliche Größenordnung, wenige. Auf der anderen Seite ist die Frage schon berechtigt. Da läuft halt einmal ein Programm, über dessen Softwarequalität du einfach nix weißt. Also ja, du installierst dir irgendwie noch eine weitere große Angriffsfläche, wo einmal der gesamte Internetverkehr gegen klatschen kann und Leute! Dann auch noch sämtlichen Traffic zu sehen bekommt. Also dann ist das halt nicht Opera, sondern das ist halt ein Stück Software mit uneinschätzbarer Softwarequalität auf deinem Telefon, die du noch zusätzlich installierst.
Okay, das heißt, wenn ich euch jetzt frage, empfehlt man einen Adblocker, würde ich dir sagen, ne, wir können jetzt keinen Adblocker empfehlen, deswegen frage ich lieber, welche Adblocker benutzt ihr denn?
UBlock Origin und für den restlichen Tracker fickt man eigentlich Ghostory weg.
UBlock, ist das Desktop oder Mobil oder beides?
Ich Desktop.
Dito.
Auch nur Desktop.
Und Mobil nehmt ihr keinen Werbeblocker?
Surf ich eigentlich nicht, nee.
Wow, ein Mensch aus dem letzten Jahr.
Ich hab Spiele und mein Chat auf dem Telefon.
Und ihr surft auch nicht mobil?
Soweit es geht nicht.
Eigentlich nur wenige Seiten. Die vorher schon.
Okay, warum seid ihr alle auf UBlock Origin gekommen?
Das sind halt die, lieb gemeint die, die wirklich Hardcore-Spinner. Die meinen das so und die fangen da nicht an, wie andere Werbeblocker dann irgendwann mal sich als Wegelagerer aufzuschwingen und bestimmte Werbung noch durchzulassen für Geld.
Magst du da konkreter werden?
Ja, das würde mich jetzt auch interessieren.
Die Firma AdBlock Plus, die quasi Marktführer in den Werbeblockern ist, die hat dann irgendwann mal, nachdem sie groß genug geworden sind mit Marktanteilen von 25% der Internetbenutzer, wie zumindest Deutschland weit, 25% der Internet angeblich laut der Werbeblocker-Studie. Und nachdem sie groß genug geworden sind, haben sie dann gesagt, na gut, ist ja nun nicht so, dass wir verhindern wollen, dass Leute über Werbung ihre Angebote finanzieren können im Internet. Dann sorgen wir mal dafür, dass wir bestimmte Werbung durchlassen, die wir vorher für gut befunden haben und für einen klitzekleinen Obolus lassen wir das dann noch zu. Nennen die, glaube ich, ethische Werbung, wenn ich da jetzt nicht Dinge durcheinander werfe. Und das ist eigentlich nicht, wofür ich mir einen Werbeblocker installiere. Da will ich allein wegen der Sicherheit, dass die sämtliche Werbung rausfiltern und will dann nicht quasi dem Wegelagerer ausgeliefert sein, dass der dann am Ende doch was durchlässt.
Naja, aber ist es nicht sozusagen, gibt es denn ein Gegenmodell zur Online-Werbung? Also ich meine, die Frage ist tatsächlich nicht unberechtigt.
Es gibt Webseiten, die das explizite Modell haben. Wenn du ein Abo abschließt, also einen monatlichen oder wie auch immer gearteten Obolus zahlst, dann kriegst du ein Login oder kriegst eine andere URL, mit der du unsere Seite besuchst und dann kriegst du denselben Inhalt zu sehen, allerdings komplett werbefrei.
Also bei Forbes zum Beispiel?
Nee, das gibt's. War das nicht bei Google? Also so eine deutsche IT-Seite war das auf jeden Fall, die das angeboten hat.
Aber selbst dann, die Preise sind ja immer da irgendwie sehr hoch. Also weil das Internet funktioniert ja für die meisten Leute nicht so, dass man diese eine Seite hat, wo man hingeht und sagt, okay, dann kriegst du auch 10 Euro im Monat von...
Gut, dass du fragst. Ich hab durch Zufall aus Interesse mal bei den großen Zeitungen rumgefragt, was man eigentlich so üblicherweise für einmal draufkriegen, dann als Werbekunde wert ist.
Also wenn ich sage, wie viel du durch Werbung verdienst, wenn ich mir einen Artikel angucke?
Das ist jetzt gerade eigentlich so der Preis für... Der realistische Preis für so ein Stück Artikel ist ja genau das, was sie gerade an Werbung verdienen, dividiert durch Anzahl der Leute, die da draufgeklickt haben, wenn sie schwarze Zahlen schreiben. Und da gibt es Magazine, die tun das und die sind auch ziemlich offen in dem, was sie sagen. Und was ich jetzt als konservative Zahlen kommunizieren darf, ist irgendwie so unter 10 Cent pro Artikel, mit dem man so anguckt.
Also die verdienen quasi an mir 10 Cent?
Weniger als 10 Cent.
Weniger als 10 Cent, okay. Wir haben ja schon gelernt, dass quasi aber das Geld, was ich ausgeben müsste für denselben Preis, wäre dann nochmal höher.
Das hab ich jetzt nicht verstanden.
Ach so, die kriegen ja nur die, also die armen Werbetreiber. Ach so, die kriegen, wenn ich der Zeitung direkt Geld gebe, dann verdienen die Werbetreiber gar nicht.
Genau.
Das heißt, wenn ich der Zeitung direkt 10 Cent pro Artikel geben würde, gibt's dann irgendwie so, wie viel lese ich denn durchschnittlich im Jahr?
Ich hab das geguckt, so bei der Plattform war ich so bei 120 Artikel. Das heißt, als ich es hochgerechnet hab, bin ich für unter 10 Euro rausgekommen. Jetzt weiß ich nicht mehr wie genau, aber das war so ein Jahresabo für irgendwie sämtliche Artikel, die mich da interessiert haben, wäre irgendwie bei knapp 10 Euro rausgekommen. Und das wär ich irgendwie spielend auch bereit, da zu bezahlen, um dann...
Das ist interessant, das würde mich tatsächlich mal interessieren, ob Leute... Also, wir haben jetzt eine 2 Stunden drüber gesprochen, und dann überlegt man sich das so, und dann sagt man, ja, okay, so 10 Euro im Jahr, das wär schon ganz geil. Wenn man es hochgerechnet sagt, okay, 100 Euro im Jahr, und dann sozusagen alle News-Seiten, die ich lese, sind dann...
Das ist lustig, dass du diese Zahl sagst, weil am Ende bleibt diese Kohle immer bei nur bestimmten Anbietern hängen. So was wie Google, die damit... 60 Prozent, jetzt will ich nicht lügen. War eine große Zahl. Über 50 Prozent bleibt da hängen. Und denen ist ein User 100 Dollar wert im Jahr. Das ist so die Größenordnung, was die damit einsacken. Das heißt, für sämtliche... Lassen sie mal, wenn es 50 Prozent sind, dann lass es so ein User 200 US-Dollar pro Jahr, was da an Werbung reinkommt, sein. Und für den Preis sollte man sich eigentlich freikaufen dürfen. Fänd ich jetzt. Und so wär's mir eigentlich auch, glaub ich, auch wert.
Und das Interessante ist auf Seiten, es gibt ja jetzt auch Bestrebungen der Verleger, über eine quasi zentrale Plattform Artikel einzeln bezahlen zu lassen. Und was halt auffällt, gerade wo Erdgeist diese Zahlen genannt hat, ist eigentlich, dass ein Artikel bei diesen Portalen einfach mal eine ganze Größenordnung teurer ist. Also da reden wir halt nicht irgendwie von 10, 20 Cent, sondern von 75 bis 2 Euro. Und das ist halt mal eine ganz andere Nummer. Und wenn ich mir überlege, klar, so eine Zeitung, wenn ich die lese, das kriegt man immer vorgebetet von den Verlegern, das ist eine Mischkalkulation. Und wenn man jetzt den einen Artikel kauft, dann liest man aber die ganzen Anzeigen nicht. Und deswegen müsste der teurer sein. Aber es ist trotzdem spannend zu sehen, dass da offensichtlich noch eine ganze Menge Unterschied ist zwischen dem Preis, der real ist, wo ja offensichtlich die Medienhäuser sich auch finanzieren können. Und dem Preis, der da auf diesen Portalen abgerufen wird, für einzelne Artikel.
Ich würde mich, was mir jetzt natürlich interessieren würde, ist sozusagen jemand, der die Sendung gehört hat, und jetzt sozusagen über die Auswirkungen von anderen Werbung Bescheid ist, Bescheid weiß, ob er jetzt sagen würde, ok, 100 Euro im Jahr oder sagen wir 10 Euro im Jahr für dieses eine Zeitungsangebot, was ich wirklich gerne mag, wären schon ok für mich. Weil es ist ja ganz oft so, dass ein Bewusstsein dafür, dass es eigentlich eine gute Idee ist, Geld für Dinge zu bezahlen, häufig nicht da ist. Also ich finde, man sieht das immer ganz deutlich im App Store, wo die ganzen kostenlosen Spiele total beliebt sind, aber halt totaler Crap, aber die Leute einfach sich nicht durchregen können, Geld zu bezahlen. Also falls ihr da gerade draußen sitzt und sagt, ja irgendwie 10 Euro, fände ich eine gute Idee, dann könnt ihr gerne noch mal kurz anrufen, 0371 77 97 110 und Bescheid sagen, ob euch das überzeugen würde oder vielleicht auch nicht, wenn ihr sagt so, nee, trotzdem Werbung.
Hab ja noch einen. Du hast ja den...
Leute!
Was die Hörer ja immer nicht sehen ist, wie Markus da einfach in seinem Stuhl zusammensackt und sich die Hand über dem Kopf zusammenschlägt.
Doch, das kann man sehen unter Streaming...
Streaming Media CCCDE.
Gibt das Ganze auch als HD Video Livestream.
Genau, aber wir haben ja noch ein Faktor komplett außen vor gelassen, der in dieser ganzen Online-Werbung auch immer noch grad massiv in die Gesellschaft eingreift. Weißt du, draußen auf der Straße ist ja nicht so, dass man eigentlich so an Billboards, an Werbewänden vorbeifährt und sich da nicht von erretten kann. Da gibt's ja eine physikalische Grenze, was man dann wie zuflastern kann mit Werbung. Aber wenn du dich grad durchs Internet bewegst, dann ist es irgendwie nie mit dem, dass du diese Bande runterladen musst, ist ja in einer Ökonomie, die davon lebt, dass Leute Aufmerksamkeit bestimmten Dingen widmen können, ist das Verbrennen von Aufmerksamkeit von Leuten ja irgendwie auch ein Faktor für die Volkswirtschaft. Das heißt, das Nächste, was ich gefunden hab, war so eine größere Studie darüber, wie soziale Medien und irgendwie die abgelenkten Mitarbeiter und Firmen gerade, dass die 500 Milliarden Euro Schäden durch Ablenkung am Arbeitsplatz gerade verursachen. Das heißt, das ist so eine Größenordnung, die alles, was so an Aufmerksamkeit in Online-Werbung reinsteckt, kannst du dann nicht mehr in andere Dinge machen. Du kannst dich dann nicht mehr aktiv beteiligen, du kannst keine Inhalte produzieren, du bist dann halt wie für die zusätzlichen paar Minuten, die du irgendwie diese Pop-ups da wegklicken musst, wo du mit dieser Werbung konfrontiert bist, bist du abgelenkt und kannst dann, deine Aufmerksamkeit wird halt für die paar Cent, die die da wirklich verdienen, werden riesige Schäden angerichtet eigentlich in der Aufmerksamkeitsökonomie.
Ich wollte das nicht so spontan widersprechen und sagen, das ist doch Quatsch, die Werbung ist doch eh keiner mehr, es ist wie Spam-Mail, sie sortiert man weg. Aber du brauchst ja trotzdem diesen kleinen Moment, wo du die Spam-Mail wegsortierst oder das Werbebander wegklickst und der kostet natürlich Zeit. Interessant.
Ich wollte bloß gerade anmerken, du hast gerade 500 Milliarden gesagt. Früher in der Sendung hast du eine andere Zahl genannt, da waren es 40 Milliarden, das war das, was die Werbeindustrie bringt. Kleines Missverhältnis.
Aber die 500 Milliarden beziehen sich auf Ablenkung durch soziale Medien.
Also du verdienst halt 40 Milliarden dadurch, dass du 500 Milliarden Schaden machst.
Moment, die Zahlen sind halt nicht direkt vergleichbar, weil das eine die Ablenkung durch Facebook und Konsorten ist, aber das war die einzige Zahl, die ich wirklich dazu gefunden habe, weil sich einfach niemand bisher die Mühe gemacht hat, das ernsthaft zu erforschen.
Wie groß der Schaden von Werbung ist.
Wie groß der Schaden dann am Ende von Werbung ist und vor allem, so dass...
Super.
Leute, wisst ihr was wir jetzt noch haben? Wir haben jetzt noch zwei Anrufer. Der eine will zahlen, der andere nicht. Das hören wir uns noch kurz an. So, Lennart aus Mitte, 18 Jahre. Hallo, guten Tag.
Ich würde grundsätzlich zahlen, wenn ich als Schüler mich immer mehr Geld hätte als mein liebliches Faschengeld. Ich habe keine Ahnung, 30 bis 50 Euro für die meisten deutschen Zeitungen, damit ich da nicht meine 10 Cent pro...
Okay, also du würdest sagen, im Jahr 30 bis 50 Euro und dann sozusagen alle großen Zeitungen in Deutschland lesen, um dir die Werbung zu ersparen? Und war das schon immer deine Meinung, oder hast du gerade die Sendung gehört und denkst jetzt, okay, das wäre vielleicht die bessere Idee?
Das war schon so, seitdem ich mir das erste Mal drüber ernsthaft Gedanken gemacht habe, als ich über Pefe auf Maxim geworden bin.
Lennart, vielen Dank. So, und dann haben wir den David aus Karlshaus. Der will doch noch lieber Werbung kommen. Hallo, David. Hast du die Sendung gehört?
Ja, ist erst gerade eingestartet vor vier Stunden ungefähr. Und genau, die ganzen Fürsprechungen für den Adblocker gehört. Ich selbst bin ein bisschen skeptisch. Also mich stört ehrlich gesagt persönlich die Werbung jetzt nicht so. Und ich bin auch eher der Meinung, also ich bin jetzt nicht bereit, da so viel zu bezahlen. Dafür schaue ich mir die Werbung eher an. Und wie gesagt, ich nehme es jetzt auch nicht so als störend wahr. Und sehe auch eher, dass dadurch, dass jetzt immer mehr Adblocker genutzt werden, sehe ich eher die Gefahr, dass immer mehr Inhalte auch schon kostenflüssig, flüchtig werden im Netz. Und das sehe ich halt eher kritisch.
Aber hast du auch den Teil in der Sendung gehört, wo erklärt wurde, dass Werbung auch ein Sicherheitsrisiko ist?
Ja, das habe ich auch noch kurz mitbekommen.
Okay, aber das ist dir dann egal oder nimmst du in Kauf?
Ja, also ich muss dazu sagen, ich arbeite auch im Online-Marketing-Bereich.
Du musst das quasi gut finden.
Ja, ich arbeite bei einer Agentur.
Also du entwirfst diese Werbung?
Ja, genau. Auch.
Und da hast du die, also findest du... Na ja, du musst jetzt immer was immer sein müssen.
Jetzt nicht so, dass ich alles gute essen muss, aber ich sehe das halt so aus dem anderen Sicht noch. Deswegen muss ich kurz anrufen und ich hab das so ein bisschen.
Was ist denn in deinen Augen gute Online-Werbung? Es gibt ja Online-Werbungen, wo man wirklich sagen muss, es geht überhaupt gar nicht, das ist laut, das ist störend. Was ist denn in deinen Augen eine gute Online-Werbung?
Na ja, natürlich sollte die halt zielgerichtet sein. Und es gibt ja auch solche, wo der User nach bestimmten Inhalten sucht und die dann durch Werbung findet. Das finde ich zum Beispiel weniger störend. Also klar, so Pop-up-Geschichten. Viele finden natürlich auch so eine Verfolgung durchs Netz dann schwierig. Ja, klar, ich kann nicht das voll verstehen auf der anderen Seite, aber ich finde halt so ein bisschen auch, mir hat jetzt so ein bisschen die Haltung halt gefehlt, dass wie gesagt immer mehr Inhalte halt kostenpflichtig werden, gerade bei Zeitschriften, wo man dann halt viele Inhalte nicht sehen kann.
Vielleicht wäre das ja eine gute Sache.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, also prinzipiell, für mich damit ist nichts verkehrt.
Ich glaube nicht, dass alle, die Adblocker halt nutzen, wirklich bereit sind, auch dann entsprechende Beträge zu zahlen. Also das ist glaube ich ein Bruchteil.
Das ist ja genau das Problem, das wissen wir nicht, weil momentan sind die Preise halt noch so hoch, dass man sagt, das ist mir halt zu teuer, wenn ich 10 Euro pro Monat pro Zeitung zahlen muss. Ich finde es halt wirklich interessant, was dann wäre. Es tut mir leid, dass dann eine Branche arbeitslos würde, wenn das funktionier. Aber als Experiment finde ich es zumindest interessant.
Also ich kenne es nur ganz kurz von Seiten in den USA, die also komplett auf Bezahlmodus gegangen sind. Bei denen sind natürlich die Besucherzahlen massiv eingebrochen. Das hat denen aber deswegen nicht so wirklich wehgetan, weil das, was sie an Abonnenten hatten, plötzlich für sie komplett viel besser funktioniert hat. Also im Gesamtergebnis viel besser funktioniert hat, als wenn sie die vielen Seiten haben, an denen sie die ganzen Inhalte und die ganze Werbung auch ausliefern müssen.
Aber dann, okay, ich will mich kurz von David verfehlen, weil die Sendung gleich, okay sag noch ganz kurz.
Nee, ich meine es funktioniert ja auch nur zum Beispiel für solche Seiten. Es gibt ja auch einen Großteil an Werbung, der halt sich nicht so finanzieren kann, wo du keine Abos abschließen kannst, die darauf angewiesen sind, dass man eben gefunden wird im Netz.
Ja, genau, also komme ich gleich noch, dass es noch eine weitere Dimension hat. David, auf jeden Fall vielen Dank erstmal und tschüss, viel Spaß noch. Und genau, was ich sagen wollte ist, ich habe auch genau dieses Ding gelesen, es gibt eine Seite, die hat jetzt nur noch, keine Ahnung, ein paar tausend Kunden oder sowas, verdient dadurch aber mehr als mit Onlinewerbung. Also für die Seite ist es geil. Das Problem ist, dann hat man natürlich die gesellschaftliche Dimension, dass es diese Seiten gibt, die sich finanzieren, denen es gut geht, dass aber Menschen von Zugang zu den Inhalten ausgeschlossen werden. Und dann ist natürlich die Frage, wie löst man das? Oh mein Gott!
War doch bisher auch so, wer sich die Zeitung am Kiosk nicht koffen konnte, der war halt dann erstmal ausgeschlossen.
Ja, aber das ist ja sozusagen keine gute Sache. Das Schöne am Internet war ja gerade, dass wirklich jeder Zugang zu wissen hat, ohne sich leisten können zu müssen.
Pfff, das ist mir jetzt wieder in Sachen so radikal.
Entschuldigung, ich sehe doch die Leute vom Chaos Computer Club Freier Zugang zum Wissen noch mal.
Ja, es gibt irgendwie die Wikipedia, wo Leute gesagt haben, wollen was und es gibt Leute, die Inhalte anbieten und sagen, da will ich Geld für, dass es irgendwie erstmal, oder erstmal Geld haben, dass es jemand konsumiert und diese Modelle haben ja funktioniert lange.
Vielleicht bin ich da auch ein bisschen hochtrabend, aber mir wäre es zum Beispiel irgendwie wichtiger, dass ich kostenlosen Zugriff auf Sachen habe, für die ich auch irgendwie Steuergelder bezahlt habe, wie irgendwie wissenschaftliche Pape war, die jetzt hinter Paywalls verschwinden. Aber ich finde jetzt eher nicht, dass es wichtig ist. Genau, aber ich finde es jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht so bombend wichtig für die für meine Bildung und für die Menschheit an sich, dass ich jetzt irgendwie kostenlos an Sportergebnisse komme. Sehe ich einfach nicht.
Ja, also ich glaube, jetzt wird es gerade so sagen sehr beschönigend, weil ich glaube, da muss man sich wirklich Gedanken drum machen.
Es ist eigentlich so einfach. Nein, natürlich nicht.
Wenn man eine Paywall einzieht, dann hat das sozusagen schon Konsequenzen. Aber die Sendung ist vorbei. Was ich gelernt habe, ist, Online Werbung ist momentan keine so gute Sache. Ich möchte gerne einen Adblocker benutzen. Habt ihr noch etwas zu verkünden? Chaos Computer Club mäßig?
Überraschend gibt es zum Ende des Jahres ein Kongress.
Ach, verrückt. Jetzt schon.
Gerade jetzt läuft die GPN, die Gulasch-Programmier-Nacht in Karlsruhe und wer sich da die Vorträge angucken möchte, kann, wenn er hier den Stream zu Ende geguckt hat, auf media.ccc.de, sich die restlichen Vorträge angucken und die, die ihr verpasst habt, die könnt ihr als fertige Vortragsvideos bereits angucken unter media.ccc.de.
Sehr schön. Dann bedanke ich bei allen Teilnehmern, Stefan und THS, die nicht mehr dabei sind, Erdgas, Danimo und Henrik, die im Studio waren. Vielen Dank. Sehr gerne. Gerne, gerne. Was wird denn da gelacht? Raus jetzt. Hier kommt jetzt nämlich Flo Heil, er wird euch den Rest der Nacht mit Punk-Musik erfreuen. Mein Name ist Markus Richter und ich habe noch eine wichtige Nachricht für euch. Lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups. Tschüss!